well yeah dad that pretty much brings
the death-knell doesn't it
[Applause]
[Music]
Netflix has canceled daredevil and yeah
I'm back and check the date it was eight
months ago that I did my video saying
that I was expecting all these shows to
wrap up and while I was wrong about I
was wrong about the timing in that both
Jessica Jones and the Punisher ended up
both getting one more season which I
didn't think was gonna happen it does
now look like I was ultimately right and
everything is panning out getting
canceled cuz if they have canned
daredevil like for me right now the only
big question is do they drop the
pretense and just admit up front that
the currently in production third season
of Jessica Jones and second season of
Punisher are going to be the last for
those respective shows or are they gonna
keep up the pretense and actually let
those go to air and then announced the
cancellation afterwards because there's
no way there is no way that they do any
more of this stuff after the fact now
there's a couple things I want to
address about this about the show in
particular and about the you know what
could happen with all of this stuff
afterwards so this is not a decision
being made by Disney Netflix has the the
control over whether or not these shows
continue so it's Netflix is call if
these get canceled and when and for as
long as they want to keep them running
the license to use them gets renewed so
before anyone gets all conspiratorial
that Disney is telling Netflix to get
rid of it Disney actually can't that's
not the agreement that they have Netflix
has control of these things now once
these shows get cancelled Disney does
get VIP back to be able to do with it
what they want and I'll come back to
that in terms of what maybe could or is
more or less likely to go on as far as
that goes let's come back to daredevil
specifically first of all I say
in my review of season 3 that I would be
okay with that being the last season and
I stand by that I I know they set up a
couple of things they set up some more
stuff to go on with bull's eye but I
feel like they they sat in a way at
least that I found satisfying wrapped up
the kingpins storyline and that was kind
of what I was in the show for that was
the big hook for me in season 1 it's
what I missed the most in season 2 and I
felt satisfied with what we got in
season 3 so I'm good with it ending
there all things considered
now again Jessica Jones and the Punisher
are going to get their next seasons
because they're already in production I
think actually they might both be done
shooting in the R&R in post-production
at this point but like that's gonna be
yet for these things there there is no
question that these things are winding
down and are being you know put on the
back or not put on the background of
being just done Netflix is done with
them so what does that mean for these
shows in the future of these characters
well here's the first thing that won't
happen the shows that seasons that have
already been produced so the defenders
two seasons of iron fist two seasons of
Luke Cage three of daredevil ultimately
three of Jessica Jones and two of
Punisher are not going to migrate over
to the Disney streaming app that's
coming out I think as 2020 is supposed
to launch because again Disney does not
actually have the control of these
things what Netflix at Netflix had an
arrangement that was a standard
licensing of IP and much like even
though Disney because they own Marvel
owns spider-man even even when they
integrated the spider-man into the MCU
they didn't suddenly gain control of all
the other spider-man movies Sony had
ever made those are still Sony's these
shows will still be Netflix as shows so
those are never going to move over and
Netflix has real
that I I believe I mm-hm should've
double-checked that I saw that somewhere
and but it like it tracks there's no
reason that this would ever move over in
addition of the fact that Disney has
said repeatedly that they are not
attempting to put r-rated content on the
Disney streaming service
now there's an open question to whether
or not they're gonna have a secondary
streaming service considering that when
they bought Fox they actually got their
hands on a lot of r-rated IP and back
catalogue so what the heck happens is
that we don't know but it will not be on
the Disney streaming service Disney Plus
I think they're officially calling it so
it that that's not gonna end up there
and these even if they were to come off
Netflix they still wouldn't end up there
because of the branding that Dizzy's
doing with the whole thing so assuming
that the shows you know are other word
that the rest get cancelled can Disney
continue the shows on their own
streaming service because I mean
sometimes shows change networks happened
with Brooklyn nine-nine not too long ago
they could I would be shocked if they
did though because again the first thing
is the tone of these things doesn't
match what they are going for on their
own streaming service so they'd have to
be reconfigured in the first place even
if they were going to do that but the
other thing is they'd have to
renegotiate all the contracts with these
things because the all the actors and
everybody their contract was with
Netflix not with Disney so if Disney
wanted to bring them back they would
have to get everybody back get everybody
to sign contracts again they actually
probably have to strike up a new
licensing agreement with Netflix because
even though Disney owns say daredevil
and all the characters associated with
it the specific version of daredevil
that was put up on Netflix is Netflix is
interpretation it's their copyrighted
interpretation so Disney doesn't just
get to continue that on their own
without entering into basically a
licensing agreement of the licensed
material it like it gets weird so
strictly speaking it is not impossible
that Disney could continue these shows
but there's really no reason for them to
do it especially given that Netflix
while they won't announce their actual
viewing numbers is saying that the
reason they're cutting all these choses
they all had big viewer drop-offs so
there's really no motivation for Disney
to go through the headache and the
hassle to read to pick these things up
again from where they left off so that I
don't see that happening at all so the
question then becomes what does happen
with this IP and this ends up being one
of those situations where the artistic
interests are going to clash with the
business interests because the artistic
interest would say don't do anything
with any of them for a while because
we're fresh off a recent interpretation
you know from Netflix so we need to just
let these things sit let people digest
and be done with that then we'll do our
own thing a little bit later down the
line and the business logic is these are
known quantities these are established
ip's these are characters people know if
we if we put them on the back burner
don't do anything with them we're
leaving money on the table so I'll be
interested to see how that clash
resolves they're not gonna kick these
things up immediately because Disney is
already working on shows MCU Marvel
shows specifically for the streaming
service that are much more intimately
connected with the film's like in the
one they're working on right now or at
least have announced and are in
development on is Scarlet Witch in the
vision and obviously with the intention
of bringing those actors in from the
from the films and let's be honest as
much as we have the promise of all this
being part of the MCU and like
technically it is the Netflix shows
never really made that connection very
strongly and it only ever kind of went
in one direction like the Netflix shows
would occasionally reference the owed
the Chitauri invasion of New York and we
saw a little bit of Chitauri weaponry in
Luke Cage that's kind of it though and
there was nothing in the films which are
much more widely watched than the next
flick so that ever acknowledged the
Netflix series so this was a very
threadbare connection that really only
went one direction so there for the
continuity hounds and this is gonna
drive you guys crazy and I'm sorry but
you're not it I
I'm not I don't consider myself a
continuity hound but I'm the people who
it's really gonna bother that like
they're gonna kill what is considered to
be a segment of the existing continuity
and then possibly replace it and negate
all that yep
Disney won't care and as far as the
continuity goes like it there was so
little connective tissue it's not that
hard to excise really at all and it's
funny cuz you think back you the MCU has
ditched more stuff than you tend to
think of given how much of a well-oiled
machine it is at this point I mean you
know we tend to remember oh yeah they've
replaced actors because roti was
originally Terrence Howard but there's
nothing like there's hope in whole plot
threads dropped whatever happened to the
guy who was going to become the leader
in the Incredible Hulk
you know that so cutting stuff loose
isn't exactly new ground for for Marvel
and the MCU that said you know cutting
stuff loose and then completely and then
bring it back as a whole new thing that
basically says flat-out yeah that other
version didn't happen before that would
be new territory but I still would
imagine that there's enough of a
business interest in making use of these
characters that it's going to happen
eventually exactly when and how it
happens that is an open question because
even though these are characters that
have been on a streaming service have
been on a TV show once Disney gets them
back they can put them in the movies
again I would expect they will get new
actors and they will be new
interpretations but they can put them in
the movies they're not restricted to
have to keeping them in TV but all of
this is gonna be like two to four years
died like two years soonest I would say
four years is the more realistic down
the road before we see any of these
characters turn up again and that's not
because of the artistic side saying let
it rest for a while winning out that's
because as we've already seen with
Disney taking over the x-men stuff they
are not going to reconfigure their
existing plans in order to fast track
the stuff they just got their hands on
you know Kevin fight you said repeatedly
like look we have our own plans going
forward for a while once we
have control of xmin again we will do
something with that but we're not gonna
like jam that in and scrap all the
existing plans and I expect that to hold
the same for when they get the get a
hold of these other characters back
again and from Netflix so the sort of
that like the lingering thing in the air
is like what when they actually do
something whatever it is however it is
whether it's film or TV what are we
gonna be looking at and for my money
their best bet is to do something
distinctly different from what the
Netflix version was and I mean the easy
way to go with them and you could do
this with pretty much every character
except Jessica Jones and maybe the
Punisher but basically just to make them
more comic book II because if you lean
if you lose the gritty you know grounded
street-level elements of daredevil and
Iron Fist and Luke Cage and lean into
the more over-the-top stop which is you
know Netflix it and it partly is a
stylistic choice and partly because the
over stops top stuff is more expensive
and you lean into that and you lean into
the garishness and you put iron fist in
the suit and you know you do that kind
of stuff it will have a distinctly
different feel and a distinctly
different flavor to it I mean let's not
forget there was not a ton of time
between the end of the Amazing Spider
Man and spider-man homecoming but I
think a big part of how they got away
with that it's time for the fact that
like people didn't really seem to want
anymore of the amazing spider-man movies
was because this was a distinctly
different feel so it didn't feel like oh
we're starting over but it's essentially
the same thing we might as well have
kept the same continuities like oh no
different field different fields of the
character different fields of the world
he's inhabiting different fields of the
supporting cast okay and that's probably
what will happen with these characters
whenever they put them up now I did sort
of say Jessica Jones and The Punisher
are a little bit odd man out on that on
that possibility though because both of
them I mean not to say Punisher has
never been garish in over-the-top he has
the like nobody lie
that version of The Punisher everybody
likes the gritty version of The Punisher
so with Netflix having kind of already
tackled that I'm not sure that Disney
could safely do a new interpretation of
him that could be wildly different
because it just wouldn't be the Punisher
anymore like I feel there's enough
wiggle room certainly on Iron Fist and
Luke Cage I would argue also in
daredevil said you could move them away
from the grittier stuff and still have
enough to work with you won't punish her
away from gritty and he gets kind of
silly you can look at some of the really
weird periods in the comments with him
to see that jessica jones even more so
because she's such a recent character
she was the newest created out of all
these so she has much less of a back
history and while you can argue how you
know close to the comics in terms of the
details of the story or the specifics of
the characterization the feel of it is
very true to the comics and it's kind of
hard to go another direction with her
because what we got on the screen is
kind of her whole shtick
she's damaged and drinks a lot and deals
in you know the underside of what goes
on around here that's what they
presented us there really is not another
way to go with her so I would say that
there's a pretty good chance jessica
jones is going to be the one out of this
lot who we just don't see again I like
not definitely not before we see any of
any of the others because I think that
that property is is young enough that a
lot of people are going to consider just
this the existing show of Jessica Jones
to be the definitive Jessica Jones
whereas even something like The Punisher
you can look back and say oh well
there's the Dolph Lundgren movie in the
Thomas J movie and the Ray Stevenson
movie and now we got things like they're
all very well maybe not warzone which is
why I love warzone but they're there
their variations on the gritty revenge
thing but you know there's been enough
it's been touched on enough again that
you think oh what's one more Jessica
Jones it I do think it would be a bit
more of a you know why do it again it's
been done and
you can't do it better than that but but
we'll see so like I said these
characters Disney will get them back
Disney will probably end up using most
of them at some point but again my call
is four years out and it could be film
it could be TV it kind of depends on
what they want to do with their TV and
they're streaming space III would think
it might honestly be more likely that
they show up in film possibly initially
in supporting roles just because it will
beg less comparison than if they do a
streaming show because then you I mean
we're already gonna be comparing on this
earlier version of Luke Cage or Danny
ran to any later incarnation but you
really can't avoid the comparison if you
do it in the same format so yeah I think
that's kind of where I land on that but
yeah daredevil canceled the other ones
are on borrowed time because I'd like
there's no doubt in my mind about that
but what are your thoughts on all this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff you can do because
there's buttons and there's links and
there's a link to my patreon if you feel
like supporting me that way if you don't
don't worry about it other links you can
check out don't want to look at those
that's fine too because at the end of
the day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]